In the toxic Google.
My name is Kevin Belk.
And today on the rock,
the casbah.
So let's welcome Mr Bill Murray and Mitch Glaser.
MMM.
You guys about a wonderful film.
You play a Richie lands you wrote and produced the film.
And so can you talk about just the story?
Um,
the basic story is bill's character,
bitchy lands is kind of a third rate,
never was on his back down on his luck.
Um,
rock manager.
I was gonna say sleazy rock manager,
but it's kind of self explanatory.
Yeah.
Redundant.
And um,
who,
uh,
takes his last act,
who was his secretary of play by Zooey Deschanel,
uh,
to co to Cabo and to Afghanistan to do Uso tour,
which is his way back into the big time.
And she freaks out because w,
you know,
this is takes place five or six years ago.
Uh,
and,
and still,
you know,
a terrifying place if for,
for all the reasons she freaks out,
steals his money,
his passport,
his wallet leaves them stranded in Afghanistan.
And the rest of it,
kind of the,
the,
the journey plays out from there.
But what basically what happens in the,
in the movie is that he uses his rock manager skills.
Um,
again,
redundant,
I guess.
Uh,
he hears a wonderful singer in,
in,
uh,
in southern Afghanistan,
a girl singing in a cave and realizes that this is the voice he's never heard
before.
And,
and managers,
managers or into the Afghan star competition,
which is based on,
it's a,
it's their American idol and it does exist.
And,
um,
and,
and Richie lands does that.
And that's basically the engine of the movie,
I would say.
Right.
You were there.
Okay.
Can you hear us if we don't use these microphones?
Not The same,
Huh?
We need him.
Yeah,
that's,
that's enough.
I mean,
you want to leave some mystery for the people that,
hey,
so your character,
Richie lands,
you've talked about how he has been influenced by a lot of agents and managers
that you've kind of met over in your life.
And Bill Graham I think was one of them too.
And Bill Graham certainly was one hilarious episode of rock and roll manager,
promoter,
someone that I got to witness on a couple of occasions.
And,
uh,
another cat we know in New York named Ron Delsener who's just nuts,
just really know,
probably suing us.
Big Guy.
But he's nice.
He,
he,
you know,
they're both very,
Dell Delsener is really funny.
Constantly self deprecating.
Well,
uh,
cutting people's heads off.
He's just lots of fun.
But um,
how are y'all doing this afternoon?
Go?
They're in love with you guys.
So you guys have known each other for years too.
So you guys knew each other back from the SNL days?
We have,
yeah.
I was introduced to bill,
uh,
our mutual friend John Belushi was a friend.
I'd done a piece on him in [inaudible] 77 and John,
I became friends and I was sitting in a studio eight h and a New York Saturday
night live and John Wave,
somebody over from behind me and this guy comes over and he goes,
Mitch,
this is Billy,
the new kid.
And um,
so we met in [inaudible] 77,
but we became close,
you know,
as collaborators on scrooge and 87,
which,
which I wrote with my late writing part of my,
yeah,
go down here.
And Billy was in,
um,
well we've worked together a lot and over the remaining 30 years.
Yeah.
Cause you guys had scrooge and passion play,
which was your first film you directed.
Yep.
Villain bill was in.
And then,
um,
uh,
what's it call it?
Charlie's angels.
And you know,
I was a writer on for nine weeks.
And the first Charlie's angels,
um,
the real one.
The real one.
Yeah,
the classic.
How do you direct bill?
Uh,
it,
it was a dream.
I mean,
you know,
w w fortunately we knew each other.
The bigger question was how did I direct Mickey Rourke?
But that's a whole nother,
there's a whole nother visit.
Um,
no,
he's,
you know,
bills,
the bills.
It's weird from him sending here,
but he's the best,
you know,
to,
to collaborate with.
Um,
he's a great friend,
but he brings a lot of energy and,
and,
and um,
in all those years of,
of talent to,
to what he does.
And he's easy.
He's great to direct.
I mean,
he loves to collaborate.
It was,
it was a dream.
You guys have another special coming up with Netflix,
a very merry Christmas and that you're riding with Sofia Coppola.
Exactly as well.
Yeah.
And so,
uh,
what keeps bringing you guys just get,
it's like,
what is that collaboration?
What does it like just to continue to work with your friend?
Well,
Hollywood is a tricky place and,
uh,
when you have a,
if you last long enough,
you have some,
you have a career involves really nightmarish episodes.
She has some really bad episodes.
If you don't have them,
you didn't really have a career and you weren't really there so you can have a
career that,
you know,
I was very lucky.
I had a lot of success early on.
And then along the way,
you,
you meet some real monsters.
You meet some people who are just have incredible positions of authority without
any of the qualifications for them.
Do you know what kind of people I'm talking about?
You meet people like that,
that are just incapable of getting out of their own way in our fearful of
sharing a responsibility.
They're just not able to,
uh,
work with,
they don't play well with others.
You know,
they just don't.
And so they do.
Having those experiences where you work with someone,
then
you do your best every day and you make everything better every day.
And they still don't understand that,
you know,
that you should be,
I'm here to help.
I'm not here.
It's not about me.
I'm really here to help.
But uh,
go on a little too much about it because I've had a,
it's like a,
it's like a five o'clock in the afternoon coffee.
I'm going to get emotional.
But
uh,
so we had some of these monsters things happen.
Look,
cause it's scrooge was,
we had a character who was the director who was,
it was jaw dropping.
I could,
I mean if you had a few hours and like half of a bar,
we could get to the,
some of these stories,
but just dealing with this guy and making a movie about Christmas and really the
Dickens story of scrooge and how you could miss that one.
How you could,
how you had to be reeducated on that one every four hours was it was mind
boggling.
So that was really,
that was a very important moment where you realized,
you know,
if you have to go to war with someone,
you better go with someone who's been in before,
you know,
who spend through something horrible and then you don't have that.
There's no fear and you realize,
well,
if you just keep playing your game,
you know,
and my feeling always is when we work together and we write together that if it
makes us laugh or moves us,
then I'm cool.
Then I,
then I go in armored and,
and I,
you know,
I can't be challenged because,
um,
that's the first initial hurdle or the person you want to please as your writing
partner.
We've written a script together and,
and um,
you know,
we laugh at the same things.
It's,
it,
it's,
it's been wonderful.
What makes a Bill Murray Movie Bill Murray movie.
So what are those elements that you put in there?
Hmm,
I'm right here.
Right.
Excellent.
Maybe you could answer with Bill Murray.
Well,
what makes a movie number one prep services?
Get Bill Murray in it.
Yeah,
we can move on.
No,
it's just,
I dunno.
I guess it partly that I guess a lot of it is being in it.
MMM.
Uh,
you know,
I just do the ones I like.
I don't have any agenda.
I don't have any kind of move that I want to go a certain way.
Particularly.
I've just had this funny career where I started out doing comedies and then I
ended up,
uh,
doing more serious roles and I wasn't intending to do it that way.
And now this movie's funny again.
Now there was,
we do have a mutual friend who said,
when I was laying on my back on the,
in Venice at the end of some of the photo,
and he said,
Bill,
you know,
you do these sad movies and you ended up taking him home with you.
You know,
and you know,
your life as an always fun anyway.
Maybe you should think about doing something funny.
And it's funny when,
when you're laying on your back on marble,
you know,
it's just changes everything because you're a little bit more receptive.
But this just happened to come up up.
Not hard upon that.
But soon after there was a movie
aware there was a chance to be funny.
And I thought,
well if you,
I,
I do believe that if you can,
right,
you must write.
And I do believe if you can be funny,
you should be funny.
People need funding.
They need funny.
Moving on from that terrible question I just asked,
you know,
I tried to help
Bill Murray help me.
All right.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the interesting thing about this,
or he was like,
Richie lands tries to bring a lot of American culture.
Have you seen this movie?
Yeah,
we just had last night.
You all saw it.
A lot of us are.
Yeah.
How many blue?
Yes.
Good.
We still got some major box office to corral.
Yeah.
Okay,
so you saw it anyway.
All good.
Okay,
go ahead.
We tried to bring a lot of American culture into Afghanistan.
You guys filmed in Morocco?
So what?
So it wasn't quite a gas,
Dan,
but what did you see in that culture that maybe we should be bringing back here
to the Western world?
It was amazing actually because we filmed during Ramadan,
uh,
July of 2014,
June,
July of 2014.
Um,
and there were,
there were options.
I was telling Billy earlier,
you know,
producers were saying you should do it in New Mexico,
but from the beginning of the movie had to have the feel of the Muslim world.
I mean it just did.
And um,
so we were really serious about that.
Um,
so half our crew was a,
was a Muslim crew and,
and experiencing Ramadan with them.
And you know,
Bill kind of insist that you,
you take a huge bite out of life wherever you are.
But,
um,
there you are in Marrakesh and Morocco.
So we,
you know,
he had two of his sons with him and,
and uh,
on weekends my wife and I would join them and went to Fez and robot and s Wera
and we really got that.
They went up to the atlas mountains were really did,
I mean we left after seven weeks and bill stayed,
you know,
took this cause it was so,
so powerful.
But there were moments there that are,
um,
there'll be with me forever.
Just,
just,
you know,
the beauty of,
of a,
of the city,
the culture and uh,
and getting a chance to work in a place like that was,
was a dream.
And we also did shoot,
there's a woman named Galora who,
um,
works for advice,
who shot all the couple cobble footage in the movie.
So anytime you don't see an actor,
but it's all the footage of people watching the TVS and the,
you know,
all that was from Afghanistan.
Um,
and a beautifully shot and seamless really.
I thought it was a,
it really was a magical two months for all of us.
And,
and the movie,
the movie,
the end of the day is about what's universal.
I mean,
it really,
you know,
not what separates us,
but a father loves his daughter.
Um,
every,
everybody loves music and loves to laugh and,
and uh,
and who better to
take us through that?
When you,
it was a,
I don't know if any of you ever been to Morocco.
It's a beautiful place.
I strongly recommended as a place to visit and see,
and I made a joke to the day.
It's like,
it's,
it's entry level Africa,
you know,
you get in and it's sort of the easiest way into sort of go like,
hey is a whole different world here.
And it's of an entry level
Muslim world too because it's,
it's a predominantly Muslim country and it's a,
you know,
what we might call like a softer,
gentler Jen,
gentler,
less strident,
uh,
most of them conveniently and sort of look,
Indonesia is easier and it's not,
you know,
you have some sort of anticipation or fear or anxiety about some sort of
reactionary Muslim and these are people that sort of read the book the way it
reads,
you know,
they don't,
they don't reinterpret it in a,
in a bizarre,
unusual fashion.
They,
it's pretty straightforward.
And so when we come there with American culture,
that's your question.
We come there with our American movie making and the way we treat people.
Well,
the Ramadan thing was a very big thing.
You know what Ramadan is?
The people don't eat or drink through the in the daylight hours.
And because this was a late Ramadan in July,
these are the longest day as long as no longer days of the year.
So it was a bad time to be having in the hottest.
So there's just a struggle.
Everyone's struggling through it and you know,
even if you're not a Muslim,
you're,
you feel this struggle all round you and that uh,
you know,
if that sort of relationship that you get with someone where this is how I treat
you,
this is how we talk,
this is how we walk back and forth to the job is how we carry something
together.
This is how we move around in a circle.
This is how we walk back and forth to lunch.
All that sort of just,
you know,
it's sort of,
there's a German lands in you.
It was,
I probably given to us much earlier on in life.
But that connection grows through the time.
So when the time comes,
when the days get hard and the days are long and movie days are long,
they're unsafe,
insufferably long and there's no point in the,
in the locals to quit before they can eat anyway.
So they just want to keep going because if we stay working on the job until
dark,
then we get to eat on the movie,
sort of,
you know what I mean?
And then then it's like,
then we all sort of break,
right.
And we stopped and that was good.
People didn't have to drive all the way to their homes.
The movie provided a meal.
When the sun went down,
we stopped and we ate.
And even if we had to keep going,
we stopped and we ate and everyone stopped an aid and all the different
departments.
When we don't work now,
we stopped and we eat as as a group.
And you feel it?
It's onscreen.
I mean,
you fit,
you feel,
you know,
as bill says,
the,
that,
that the exotic and the unusual and the magical of it on screen,
you know,
it really,
it really does.
I noticed that last night we watched the screen or two nights ago whenever we
saw the movie again and the credits roll and you're used to seeing,
you know,
kind of like show business names like,
hey,
there's wanting Westmore,
you know,
you know some guy that,
and they're all Muslim names.
I don't know anyone,
you know,
it's like,
well,
here's the,
everyone had a nickname.
So he,
it's like,
I don't know who likes her roof guy named doll is,
you know,
but everyone had nicknames and you'd have to go like,
ah,
you know,
you point
because the names,
you never knew everyone's entire name,
which could be three or four words and,
and it,
but the fact that here's this American movie that has an entire crew,
that's not,
that's not American.
It was,
um,
you know,
you feel good about that.
You guys brought rock the casbah to comicon this year,
which had to be insane.
It's,
what was that experience like?
Because there's both of your first,
right.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
And I gotta say,
uh,
neither of us had done it,
but it was in that big room and the 6,500 seat or 7,000 seat or whatever is
yeah.
And uh,
and his entrance was to smoke on the water through the back of the room.
Something I'd seen Mick Jagger due to different song clearly.
But,
uh,
it was,
it was epic.
I mean it was really exciting and a bill bill insisted on leaving the same way,
which was insanely bold.
Well,
I was charmed by it.
I had a kind of a
okay,
you know,
just to healthy and maybe,
cautious attitude about people that dressed as wonder woman,
you know,
especially if they weren't a woman.
I felt funny about them.
So Woo.
That's actually a perfect time actually.
So we have to acknowledge it.
You're from Chicago.
I'm from Chicago.
Cubs are playing right now.
Game for the playoffs.
So we're going to get a score check right now.
And also some cubs gear.
Didn't know.
Is there anyone out there that's a cub fan that doesn't have a cub hat?
Actually we had some lean.
I have one.
I have one,
so I'm going to let you have mine.
I'll hand it to him.
[inaudible]
brings up a great point actually.
So the Internet is this beer that is beer.
I'm not really a beer guy.
I'm more of a hard liquor guy.
You a beer girl,
right?
Yeah,
she looks very thirsty.
Can you share with her
all right.
All right,
that's good.
All right.
Popcorn too.
Okay.
All right.
Just put your hand out.
Put both hands up
both hands
and then put your gum in there.
All right,
so you're from Chicago.
How did,
uh,
growing up in Chicago shape you as a person today?
Well,
it gets very cold in Chicago in the winter and people from out of go then go,
it
gets it.
They just can't believe that it gets that cold.
But people from cold weather,
places like Minneapolis or green bay or Chicago,
you end up trying to figure out how to entertain yourself in the cold.
And we were talking yesterday about,
sorry,
I've got a son that has a,
that has a job,
well I have two that have jobs,
but um,
he said,
you taught me how to work.
And I say I could,
you know,
I thought,
well that's how,
how did that happen?
He said it was that night we had to,
we were at Peggy's house,
my sister Peggy's house,
and she has a driveway that's very long,
very,
very long,
like maybe 60,
70 yards long.
And,
and she said,
and he said,
you and you made us shovel the snow.
What doesn't sound like a big thing.
But when you have to shovel like 4,200 square yards of,
of driveway in like a 12 inch snowstorm,
you've got to go out there several times.
You can't wait till it for it to stop or you'll never be able to do it.
You have to go out when there's four inches on the ground and then you have to
go out again when there's the next four inches on the ground and then you have
to go out.
So it's about a six hour job to do it.
Otherwise you'll never get it done.
So he,
I just wouldn't let him quit until we got it all the way done each time.
And he just couldn't believe that I was still going to be out there.
He's like,
come on old man,
give up.
You know,
it's like,
this is what we do here.
This is how we live in Chicago.
You have to get it done.
And that gets hot in the summer and people are friendly.
They're,
you know,
they were just kind of natural in front of pretty straightforward.
There's not a lot of mystery to it.
People root for the cubs for the socks or the bears or something.
And I don't know,
I come from a very big family,
so that was a great part of the education because you have to get along with,
you know,
you got to get along with people at work.
I,
you got to go in with people at home,
you know,
that's,
it's even harder sometimes.
And then,
um,
and I was a caddy and so I worked my way through school as a caddy.
And that's really when you have a great,
that's a great opportunity to,
to acquire an education because you see how you learn how to treat people.
You,
you learn how you would like to be treated.
Like you are really a slave,
you're really a servant.
The disc job description has show up,
keep up and shut up and that's where it begins.
And you,
you have to be able to last four or five hours in that mode without ever
imposing your personality on the event.
And that you see people who recognize the struggle that that is and not only
urge you to show yourself,
but they respect the effort you're giving and they treat you with kindness.
So,
you know,
it's like I can always tell someone that's like a real prick to a waiter.
I just think he's,
you know,
you should have caddy,
you really should have caddy.
You're alert.
And it was,
I was,
it was luck.
It was very,
it was just luck.
And it was just my fortune that I had to work that I got.
I got it.
So we're going to take some questions from our audience.
And a few minutes,
but we're going to bring up Dana Han client who runs their social media for
toxic Google.
And now she has some questions that she's gathered from Twitter
and from our internal folks as well.
Hey guys,
let's go ahead.
Uh,
Mitch,
this one is for you.
Um,
so your character speak Pashto and Dari and I'm sorry if I'm butchering those
languages without subtitles.
So they're wondering what,
um,
what was your sort of train of thought and not subsiding?
It was a to kind of make us a little uncomfortable.
Um,
and,
and then also what,
um,
what were the choices to have saline seeing only American songs.
Okay.
The,
the,
the Pashto and,
and,
and other languages that are used.
Um,
well there are choices not to use subtitles because we had a character,
a great acronym,
Ren who played this cab driver Rizza who's with,
with bill throughout this journey.
And there was some,
because he was such a wonderful actor.
I mean,
there's a scene around a campfire where he translates what the passion patch
tune leader is saying.
And I just thought,
and Barry Levinson agreed that it was more powerful and more beautiful to,
to hear him repeat the words here,
then both say them.
And then there's,
yeah,
there is that lag of what's,
what's he saying?
And so it really was a,
it almost a cinematic device more than,
than accuracy.
It was just something I thought would be more,
we thought it would be more powerful.
Um,
and as far as,
as far as the Cat Stevens,
that was really for three reasons.
One,
I,
you know,
I grew up in the 70s,
loved Cat Stevens from day one.
Uh,
so his music is powerful and peace train was always ending for seven years.
From the very first iteration of the script.
It was,
it was ending the movie.
Um,
but the idea that [inaudible] girl would feel better about singing a Muslim
singers songs,
even a western singer,
um,
felt important.
I mean,
it felt logical and important that,
that she wouldn't be doing,
you know,
Nicki Minaj and the,
and the,
and the cat that it would be that it would be,
you know,
as Bill's character says in the movie,
she does the Muslim west.
I mean,
she,
she feels comfortable seeing that.
Yup.
Oh,
a bill,
this one's for you.
You've played several iconic film roles.
Are there any roles that you passed on or later you thought,
I wish I had taken that or I would have taken that character in a different
direction?
Were there none that I passed on?
Uh,
that,
uh,
I really covered it,
you know,
uh,
there was one,
I w for a moment I was told I was going to be in the movie Philadelphia
and,
uh,
I didn't bring myself to see it until about an hour ago,
you know,
but,
but I liked the film and they did a good job with the movie
and,
uh,
Tom Hanks was really great.
I don't know what part,
I think I was going to play the other part,
Denzel Washington Dunes Park.
But it was,
I think it was more important.
What's the Damn Funny Bitch?
I didn't really mean that.
No,
but,
um,
but no,
I,
but I think,
I think the director Jonathan Demme,
he thought it was more important that the way the character was written,
it's sort of like Denzel is like a black man on the down,
down low was the way that it sort of came across in the film if you remember the
film.
And he thought that that was a more important thing to speak to,
I think are a very important thing to do.
More important than having me in the film.
Yeah.
So our last question is,
uh,
if you were a real rock tour manager,
what two bands would you want to manage?
Oh,
what happened before something reminded me.
Well,
I wanted to say about comicon.
Yes,
sorry.
Well,
splice.
I wanted to say about comicon that,
uh,
I,
I was charmed by that,
that group,
they were so sweet and I had the occasion of seeing the last grateful dead show
in Chicago the week before.
And it's true,
it was just delirium and there was just this joyous,
like imagine that all of these people in this room,
we're dancing completely in a completely uninhibited fashion.
Can you imagine what that's like?
And that's what it's like at a dead show.
And I hadn't seen one in a long time,
but it was 150,000 people maybe dancing completely uninhibitedly and just happy
and free and relaxed.
And the comicon crowd was that way too.
They were dressed as Batgirl or whatever,
Batman and they were laughing together and they were amusing each other and they
were delighted in each other and they were in love.
They really were in love.
I was really charmed by that.
So I just want to make that,
um,
express that.
But you asked a question about what bands,
what bands,
where I like to hear
you,
man.
What do I manage?
Well,
there was a great band back in the day called the amazing rhythm Masis and they
only had one hit song was called third rate romance,
low rent rendezvous,
which is kind of a clever song,
but the way they could play live was extraordinary.
And they were great songwriters,
really great songwriters.
And the lead fellow,
Russell Smith still writes great songs for all the country guys.
He's a Nashville guy now.
They lived down there and you can still hire the amazing racist asis,
the amazing resumes to come to your house and play.
But,
um,
they,
I never felt like they had the right people pushing them along,
that they were something that they had that was unique,
that there was a soul that they had that really came across in their live
performance and in their recordings that never was,
uh,
didn't get fostered properly.
It didn't get to show him around.
And the records are really beautiful and they're,
you know,
they're,
they're among my treasures now.
Second,
well,
I liked this fill a big head.
Todd.
Do you know,
big head Todd and the monsters?
He's a really wonderful player.
And,
uh,
I used to hit golf balls to his music.
I used to take,
take a boombox to the driving range and hit golf balls too,
that,
uh,
you know,
bittersweet,
those songs that they sing,
but he,
someone that on on his own,
he was from Colorado.
He left and moved to Chicago to learn better how to play the blues.
And he became great friends of Hubert,
someone whom we know it was one of the great elders and stayed with Hubert,
someone,
some someone and just played with them for,
I don't know,
a couple of years and was asked by his family to,
to play humor into the ground when they lowered his casket into the ground.
And he's a beautiful man who came to my party a couple of years ago,
had a lot to drink,
uh,
got sick,
on my son's a cowboy boot,
but fell asleep for a little while and then woke up around five in the morning
and played songs for two and a half hours straight.
So that's,
he's got a great spirit.
That one.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
it'd be mostly friends.
My friend Steve Jordan has a band called the verbs with his wife,
Megan Voss.
Love to manage him.
He just produced Keith Richards,
new new album with Keith and,
and a grit,
world's greatest drummer.
And then we love Jenny Lewis.
I mean,
I would,
I'd love to manage her.
They'll for the laughs
audience question.
Hey Bill.
Um,
my grandfather,
his birthday's coming up,
he's turning 91,
and it's really hard to get him to laugh and I'm,
I'm not very funny,
but you are.
So I was wondering if you could help me out with a joke or his birthday.
Okay.
I'm not,
I,
I usually forget jokes pretty quickly,
but I've got this one.
I still have it.
My brother Brian is really good with the jokes and this is,
I'm actually,
uh,
I've been appointed to an official Vatican,
a position.
I am,
I'm a,
the official Vatican,
uh,
Co consulate or whatever the hell I am to the pope on,
on humor.
It's true.
And so,
uh,
it turns out the pope wants me to play him when the movie's made.
And,
uh,
maybe we'll see that that could use agent,
that could be his agent.
But he had a program when he came to the USA tell a joke to the pope.
And so what they did was they asked people to like film themselves telling a
joke to the pope.
And I'll tell you the joke I told to the pope and
we'll see.
So he's to a antenna.
Got Married.
Uh,
that's a big news in my town.
These two antenna got married last week.
And uh,
the ceremony was,
you know,
it was okay,
was nice,
it was fine,
but the reception was extremely
Miriam.
[inaudible]
and that's,
that's PG 13.
I mean,
you can tell that.
Did you guys play with it?
Yeah.
So bill,
a lot of the work you've done in your life,
both in comedy and drama,
has dealt with artificial barriers,
human isolation and loneliness.
So maybe you have some insight.
What's one of the most common and ridiculously sad ways that we make it harder
to connect with each other?
Well,
sometimes you get asked a question and the right,
the right answer isn't right in front of you.
And you just sort of tried to,
cause it's a feeling.
It's a feeling that you're,
you're looking for.
So I have to try to feel then we're and recall the most reason feeling of this.
Okay.
So I think,
I think that
there's many ways to portray it or to show it,
but there's this feeling that we're alone.
Yeah.
And we're not alone.
Okay.
We're not alone.
And it's,
you can fool yourself that it's just you that feels pain.
You can hypnotize yourself or delude yourself that no one could ever understand
how I feel.
No one could ever,
no one's ever felt this fucking miserable as I feel right now.
And it's wrong.
Okay.
Because you felt that miserable and you felt that miserable.
And life is hard enough that the idea of elevating ourselves and making
ourselves better,
perfecting ourselves or becoming more of our true self is so daunting and so
impossible that we have to,
we have to grab and realize that we can not to do it alone.
And there's a,
there's a connection that you have to me,
certainly by asking the question and to all of us by asking the question because
you're asking all of us this question and all of us have this question
ourselves,
whether it's in the front of our head as you were speaking or if it is now,
we all have this question.
And
to let that question settled down in you is really the bravery is the courage.
It's the try.
It's a try.
You know,
you can,
you've got to try.
You know,
it's not,
it's easy to
okay,
distract yourself or to be distracted or to turn on a television or to drink a
beer or a read of cartoons or stupid anything or to just,
you know,
walk up and down stairs,
but to try to come back and say,
okay,
observance,
hey,
this is who I am right now and it's okay that I'm this person now and it's okay
that I keep coming back to this now because I'm trying to not feel that way as a
rule.
I'm trying to overcome the weakness of letting the emotions take me down.
And by seeing it in the Ed at the moment,
something changes,
like something lands in your this different and you were able to feel the grace.
It's really grace that can push you to try and it's like there's no harm in
trying.
Right.
It's not going to make is not going to break you maybe,
but there can be no harm in trying and if you try,
you feel better about yourself.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
this question is for bill.
You,
you told us earlier how you worked with a lot of monsters over the time and it
seems just in the first decade of the two thousands where the arts as they're
sometimes known.
You did a lot of independent films,
but I quite enjoy the ones that you did with Jim Jarmusch.
We'll it,
so the lost in translation with Sofia Coppola,
was that kind of,
uh,
what you turned into doing more independent films versus the,
the blockbusters or is that just what I turned into this.
Okay.
No,
I didn't really turn to it.
It wasn't a reaction to anything.
I don't,
I like I,
I didn't really have any kind of a plan.
I just,
I just do the ones I like to do.
I'm not very organized.
Like I said,
I'd do this movie seven years ago and it wasn't like,
oh that was seven years ago,
man.
No I said I'd do it.
I mean that's,
I like it.
That doesn't change.
I didn't have any religion,
any plan.
They just came this way and I had a certain kind of lock in that I feel if you
do this job and you don't completely embarrass yourself,
that you remain legitimate.
You,
you were,
you remain viable.
I've done casting myself where you look through the book and you go like,
oh here's so and so.
Oh my God,
he did that horrible watch McCall,
that movie.
Remember that piece of crap he did.
You know,
and you go and you lose that guy cause he,
anyone that would sign on to a death ship like that,
that's bad.
You can't,
you know,
you don't just don't trust him anymore.
I've been lucky about choosing like I haven't,
I haven't done anything,
you know,
for which I could be prosecuted,
I couldn't do,
you know,
and that you just stay viable.
And then sort of this next generation of people like Wes Anderson and Sophia,
they go,
we'll get that guy's okay.
He's not terrible yet.
And then you get,
you get to work more.
It's the same in every kind of career I think.
You know,
it was like a carpenter makes a great piece of work.
He doesn't rip people off.
It's like,
Hey,
this guy made my garage,
you know,
he's good.
You know,
you,
you last your,
your mark,
your reputation lives,
you know,
you don't kill it.
Thank you.
So we have two books here that you have brought with you.
Um,
importing always by Lillian Ross.
Yes.
Okay.
This is,
it's called reporting always.
She was what they call the reporter back when she started writing.
Then she became a journalist because they changed the job title.
Her name is Lillian Ross and she's most famous for writing for the New Yorker
for decades.
And she did profiles of,
you can help me here.
She had profiles of some of the most famous people anyway,
of the century,
Hemingway and chaplain and John Houston.
And there's spectacular to read her.
One of Hemingway was,
was groundbreaking because Hemingway was this mythic character,
this gigantic character.
And she,
she gave him a human voice that was beautiful to read and engaging.
You felt like you knew the man by reading her words.
Um,
she's,
she wrote for the New Yorker for many 40 years or something like that.
And she had a romance with the man who was the editor,
a secret romance with the man who was the editor of that wasn't that much of a
secret,
but it was kind of a secret romance.
And then when that editor was fired,
she's quit working for the paper for the magazine and then a new way to editor
came later and she went back to writing for them.
She's 90 now and I've read a bunch of her stuff and she's,
I've been friendly with her and I get it.
I like to tease her.
She's like a little thing,
got curly hair.
And you can just mess with her.
She's a lot of fun and she's real.
She's real smart and real funny.
So you can mess with her all you like and she'll take it.
And then any moment she just gives you look like I could bite your head off,
you know that.
And she's fun.
She's really a lot of fun to be with.
So her friend,
he asked me to do some sort of thing,
I dunno,
something modern to help her sell her book.
And I didn't know the answer to it.
And someone said,
well,
if you bring it along,
maybe some people will notice it.
There's a little,
there's a little caricature over.
She's a sweetie.
But there's,
um,
so I started looking at this book.
There's a profile of the,
do you know what the junior league is?
You know the,
the,
the women's junior league.
She does,
she did a profile here in 1954 of the women's junior league that I think might
be one of the funniest things I've ever read in my entire life.
And it's all facts.
It's just the facts,
ma'am.
Just the facts.
She just writes the facts down and you are,
I,
I mean,
I was shaking a shaking,
reading this thing anyway,
if you're in,
if you're interested in journalism or you're interested in writing or you're
interested in knowing what it's like to have real ears,
to have a higher developed sense of listening,
of hearing,
you know,
we're in this sort of state,
and what have we got?
If you said,
as you,
when you're awake and waking state,
you know,
you wake up and you've got your eyes,
then you've got your ears and your taste and your,
you know,
you've got these,
these,
these functions that these,
these aspects that you can work with her ears are like unlike anything I've ever
seen and the way she hears and the way that her ears,
um,
almost separate that,
which is essential from that,
which is not,
and she's able to recall it and put it down.
It's an amazing piece of,
of literature too.
And it's,
and yet it's not literature,
it's writing,
it's writing.
It's just facts.
And it's extraordinary.
It's called reporting.
Always.
Her name is Lillian Ross.
And a few.
Um,
I,
I was told that I the,
the idea would be to bring books out.
We have some for the,
I've got some books,
some,
so after the,
you know,
I don't know how many books there are,
but this is,
um,
this is some Dame.
She's really something.
This one,
she's a real pistol and uh,
and kind.
And then he got that one and this is a,
and then I mentioned that I was going to say something about that.
And my friend,
I said to my friend who had a funny look on his face,
you were talking about that thing about helping someone carrying something off
of a truck or something.
And we have a friend who,
who
is cursed with great wealth,
you know,
and it's
okay.
And all he does is pick up the checks of the world.
That's all he does.
And it's amazing you see on his face that he feels this sense of obligation that
because he's been blessed with this,
that he has to sort of even it up all the way across the world.
Everywhere he goes,
everywhere he goes
in the quietest,
most subtle way.
He just passes the money back.
He just tries to pass it all back.
And I said,
Gee,
I wonder if there's something you'd like me to talk about.
And he said,
his friend has a cookbook.
His friend has a cookbook,
right?
This is the guy.
It's not like,
Hey,
uh,
you know,
kept me a date with a supermodel.
No.
He's like,
um,
my friend has a cookbook.
That's the way he thinks.
And this book is called crossroads.
And our friend has this restaurant in California,
in Los Angeles called crossroads.
It's a Vegan restaurant with a really good bar,
which is the vegans blow my mind.
They really do.
It's like they're stoners and they're drunks and they're vegans.
They're just,
I don't know how they do.
I don't know.
And I'm okay.
I'm down with that.
It's like you're a Morgan and a Mormon,
and you believe,
but you've got nine whys.
Okay.
It's cool.
I'm all right.
It's just,
it's just an interpretation.
And anyway,
this fellow's name is towel Ronan,
and he wrote this book.
Crossers.
I've eaten this guy's food and it is,
it's ridiculous.
Dazzling cause he,
he,
he's a,
you know,
a trained chef and he has vegan food that doubles as tastes like,
like he'll have a,
you know,
bone yeas sauce or Lasagna or whatever.
And it,
it really is an amazing magic act.
And the food's wonderful.
It really is magic.
Yeah,
it really is.
Cause it's tastes like something that you think it is and is not.
It really is extra.
So if you eat food or know people that do,
this would be a great one to give them cause it's,
it may be the future that we have to eat healthy.
You never know.
And we have some copies for you guys too.
And we all put into those too.
Yeah.
Cool.
Just for showing up all your duties.
So I kind of want to end with this.
One of my
favorite scenes is actually not in the movie was actually the tag.
And I think that was just absolutely hilarious.
So was there any of your favorite scenes or seen that may have gotten cut just
for a time or just didn't fit in the story?
The,
the,
the tag you're referring to is,
is was the very last scene we shot on the very last day and a in Morocco and
there was just a spectacular looking older man there.
And,
and,
and earlier bill was talking about Buster Keaton earlier in the day and there is
a,
there is an an incredible invented seeing between bill and this,
this,
you know,
75 year old Moroccan mandate,
at a store kind of discussing or arguing over,
you know,
string and an elephant and how much it's gonna cost and anything else on the tag
as credits go.
So stick around and watch it because it's beautiful.
My favorite scene,
one of my favorite scenes in the movie is the scene that bill does.
I'm in one,
I mean it's a,
it's shot through a window of a,
of a truck bill gets out of the truck,
goes out,
thinks about something,
turns around and comes back to the car and delivers a scene.
There are no cuts in it.
He did it twice and uh,
I was sitting with Barry Levinson,
both of us really Mao's open.
It's just a beautiful piece of acting and insane ride,
really well written.
And um,
and uh,
yeah,
that's my favorite scene in the,
and then move it.
Yeah.
How about you?
Well,
no,
they're all perfect.
No,
I don't,
I'm trying to think of something.
I'm trying to think of something that just made a strong impression on me
watching wise.
This little man that I'd do the scene with the string with is really something.
He wasn't even an actor,
he was just a guy.
It was an amazing face.
And I basically Hungle and try to like,
you know,
like bite him down on the price of string.
You know,
it's like not a,
not a very nice scene,
but very fun.
Um,
there were,
I think the really seen that I miss that I love the most about was just being in
Morocco was seeing the way,
I've never seen people drive like this.
There's multiple kinds of vehicles.
There's,
there's still animals,
there's still animals pulling wagons,
there's big trucks.
There's semi tractor trailers,
there's a lot of these crazy three wheeled motorcycles with huge carrying racks
on the back.
Every one of them was different.
There were motorcycles that were,
that had like a,
like a bed in the back of it that we saw one that had,
hey,
there was maybe 16 feet high,
but the combinations of junk that they put into these motorcycles and drove,
and then there were people on bicycles and all kinds of different vehicles.
And I never saw people drive and miss each other like this.
They just moved off.
They were like fish,
you know,
you don't see fish crash into each other,
right.
You don't see a school of fish.
Well sorry,
you know,
they just kind of go,
hey,
like the blue angels.
But there's thousands of them.
And that's what Morocco was like.
And you'd see,
you know,
if you've ever been to Asia or someplace where you see an entire family on a
motor scooter,
there'll be five people on a motor scooter.
And the woman always dressed in beautiful color riding sidesaddle on the back.
And I think this is great.
You know there's like there's a kid in front of the dad,
there's two kids in between.
And then there's a mom and she's holding a kid and she's on the back and she's
riding sidesaddle and they'd all fall and they don't crash and they just move
like this.
They just move their really beautiful people.
Great.
Well thank you guys so much for being here.
That's right.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
go see.
Yeah,
yeah.
I have a question.
I asked it outside and I maybe one of you guys,
which one do you guys is the brains of Google?
Can I oh,
there you are.
So,
um,
so I've got a question.
Why is Google asks me for my secret password night keeps I say no,
but it keeps asking me,
isn't it smart enough to like get the hint,
I'm not going to give it out.
Why do they,
why does it keep asking it?
Shouldn't it know that I'm not going to do that?
Cause I'm just shy.
Like many things in life.
First.
Safety.
No,
I agree with you.
I believe it though about the safety,
but I just tried to,
I always feel like a guy asked me a question today,
what is,
what is your secret to life?
And I said,
if I told you my secret,
then it's not a secret anymore,
is it?
And would you ever want to be involved with someone that couldn't keep a,
would
you like to be friends with some of the,
couldn't keep a secret.
I guess I'm just going over the same old territory again,
but that's,
that's sort of how I feel.
It's nice to come here and put a face with the bicycle.
Thanks
very well.
[inaudible] I was out this weekend.
Go see a guys.
You guys [inaudible]
okay.